at the end of october and early november
there was a summit between mgm and
amazon executives and high up on the
agenda
the return of stargate
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv movie
channel
so at the end of october and early
november there was a series of meetings
between mgm executives and amazon
executives now apparently according to
my sources mgm a lot of these meetings
were about finance stuff they weren't
particularly interested the sale of mgm
to amazon has been
dragged through the courts and the
regulators and slowed down they weren't
expecting to take this long and
basically mgm is looking for direction
on what amazon expects it to do with
upcoming projects
they know that there are contracts that
need to be signed that basically amazon
are eventually going to have to pay for
so they're looking for some idea of what
amazon would like them to do they're
kind of in a bit of a limbo at the
moment of mgm because
other than projects that were already
green lit they're having to hold off on
lots of things they were planning to do
stargate included
so
there's a lot of meetings about how they
want them to do that and also a lot of
meetings about boring financial stuff
but there are also a lot of meetings
with jennifer salk from amazon and mark
burnett from mgm now these are the
really two big hitters when we're
talking about tv and movies at the two
respective companies a lot of their
meetings were about planned content
about the things that amazon intend to
green light immediately as soon as the
sale goes through
now the three main agenda points
apparently for those meetings
were the mgm back catalog
and consolidating all of that material
as much as humanly possible onto one
platform amazon prime
and getting it off other platforms
immediately now mgm don't own soul
rights for a lot of their properties a
lot of movies and tv shows are
co-produced with other companies but the
ones that they do own sole rights for
amazon fully intend consolidating all of
that onto amazon prime as quickly as
humanly possible
now the second big thing on the agenda
is james bond
there's going to be a reboot of the
james bond series there's lots of
different ways that could go and amazon
are very interested to make sure that
mgm know exactly where they wanted to go
third on the agenda is stargate and
getting that back onto our tv screens
now the main reasons why these are the
three areas that they want to discuss is
because obviously the back catalog
makes amazon a lot more legitimate now
they've been making movies and things
for a little while now they're seen as
the new boys on the block and they're
not really taken very seriously
mgm is one of the great old film studios
they're part of the great movie history
you know some of their back catalog
titles include things like ben hur and
gone with the wind and hot tub time
machine
you know some great movies
and you know they've got some of the
classics and that's the main reason why
amazon are buying them so getting their
back catalogue
consolidating to one place is high up on
their agenda
james bond financially speaking and
really critically speaking is their
biggest franchise you know
if you look at their top 100 out of the
top 20 or so
several of them are james bond movies
and i'm pretty sure that the highest
grossing movie is a james bond film live
double check but if we're talking about
high grossing movies their 10th highest
grossing film in history for mgm is the
original star game movie james bond is
the most profitable franchise they have
but second is stargate even though it's
not been on our tv screens for years now
it's still the second highest franchise
i own so amazon have come in
and basically gone what are the three
areas we can make money
the back catalog stargate james bond so
of course it makes sense that they're
going to have those conversations
already they're really coming in with a
five-year business plan but the things
that they want to prioritize are the
things that they can make the most
cha-ching on now you can look at that
two different ways really now the cynic
in me says they're just looking at the
things that are going to make them money
but really it kind of makes sense in
that they're looking at the things that
are the most valuable because they're
the things that the most popular
the reason why stargate still makes
money is because people still watch it
the reason why james bond makes money is
because of the highest grossing film of
this year already and they always make
money
people watch james bond year after year
after year
so
of course amazon are looking at their
highest most valuable franchises so how
do i know that this summit actually
happened so i was approached um a couple
of months ago now after a video i did
that that was very popular 100 000 views
on this video um i was approached by
somebody that works at mgm now he's not
high up he's not one of the big
executives or anything he's quite low
down on a pecking order um but through
that person i've been able to make a few
other contacts i've started to get an
idea of how mgm employees actually feel
about this acquisition and i can tell
you now they're not happy
the main reason why they're willing to
talk to me is because they want to have
a moan and they want to have a vent
about it and they want me to go in here
and tell you about it they want me to
tell you that they're not happy
amazon are really coming in as bully
boys apparently a lot of these meetings
hasn't been a mutual coming together of
mines of the mgm talent and the new
amazon owners it's been amazon coming in
and telling mgm executives exactly what
is going to happen
it's not been a two-way conversation
it's been bosses telling employees
a lot of mgm staff feel that amazon
aren't really that excited about the
talent that works for mgm at the moment
and their word for their jobs
they're also worried about the
intellectual properties that they own
and how amazon intends to use them one
of the things that's been raised to me
again in the last couple of days is that
brad wright is being frozen out of
stargate that amazon don't really like
the direction that brad white was
planning to take um stargate
another employee though has said that
he's actually thinks it's really good
thing that covert hit when it did in a
way because mgm were going to go ahead
full steam ahead with brad wright's
version of stargate and amazon would
probably have pulled the plug we might
have seen one or two seasons of what
brad wright had planned but then amazon
may have cut it
he also thinks that amazon to be honest
even though he's not a massive fan are
bringing a really big financial might to
the mgm studio and that he says if
nothing else they're going to get well
funded so hopefully when the stargate
franchise does re-emerge it's going to
be much better funded than it would have
been under mgm so that's a two-edged
sword he's to be fair though that person
was the only one that's actually said
anything positive about the amazon
takeover everything else everybody else
i've spoken to seem very very worried
one of the things they have talked at
this summit as well is about the time
frame for stargate's return now they
expect a movie to be on amazon prime
within 18 months of the sale being
finalized and they expect the sale to be
finalized in april or may 2022
now i think that will basically mean
that we will see a movie on amazon prime
of stargate by christmas 2023 or the
latest early spring 2024.
that will then be followed by a short
run tv series 10 or 12 episodes with one
overarching storyline
basically what we're used to seeing now
on streaming services like star trek
discovery and so on and so on 10 12
episodes one storyline
we're going to see a series every year
now even though
it seems that the movie is not going to
be necessarily connected to the tv
series they're all going to be in part
of one universe but that's giving you a
little bit of an insight into something
else that i've been told something that
at the moment i can't share with you
anymore because
i'm not 100 convinced it's true but if i
can get a little bit more information on
it then i will share it with you as soon
as i can but it's something related to
the movie that i think will surprise a
lot of stargate fans and maybe make a
few of us quite worried but that's for
another video
so
we have a time frame
we have an idea of how keying
amazon are and we have an idea of how
unhappy mgm are i really love to hear
what you think leave a comment go and
visit the facebook group that's on
psytrek i'll put a link in the
description
and you can join the channel and help me
make loads more content i really love
doing this so anything you can do to
help me would be great so please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification i will have a follow-up
video really soon as soon as i can
confirm what i've been told i'll let you
guys know
in the meantime thanks for watching and
i'll see
[Applause]
[Music]